[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
so good to see all you actual humans
um if you missed that little
pre-announcement
we all may now
not remember this but you should turn
off your ringers when you come into a
theater so please do thank you
um
tonight's speaker is actually one of the
speakers that we've worked with in a way
more than any other he's worked with us
on on many interval talks and so it's
great to have him here on this stage and
and this was you know
there's sometimes there's those books
that come out and every single person
you meet says you have to read this book
it's so relevant to what you do and of
course ministry for the future was
exactly one of these kind of books and
so we knew that we had to have uh stand
back for this and
um it was in a conversation i was having
with ram who's going to actually be
doing our
question and answer who's also a
previous speaker here
who wrote the nexus series and is now
doing investment in cleantech but i
realized there could be no better
perfect person to do the q a afterwards
so i'm so glad that both of them were
able to come and to make this talk and
that all of you are actually here making
this talk
um and i think that
one of the the really interesting things
that came out of ministry for the future
was i think how many other
organizations have been asking stan to
kind of
work with them around this concept from
that book and one of them was the uk
delegation with the cop 26 summit and so
tonight he wrote a special talk
really out of you know what he's learned
from both of these experiences and where
he thinks things are going right now and
afterwards uh mez and stan will have a
conversation on stage and please feel
feel free to fill out your question
cards there'll be someone going around
to get them thank you it's kim stanley
robinson
well thanks very much for that kind
introduction and
appreciate much appreciated
it's good to be back and it is good to
unexpected joy to see people
gathering together like this again
all come back
sweet
um i i want to before i begin i want to
dedicate this talk to michael mcgilligan
um many of you knew him better than i
did
and
the
last time i saw him he was curating a
talk i gave over at the interval on
ursula k le guin that was his idea his
invitation and it's amongst the
favorite amongst my own talks
close to the top in the top five a
beautiful evening all around
so
tonight
i'm going to talk about the ministry for
the future
and cup 26 and what i have
learned six since cop26
is it's um
a fire hose of information as we all
know
and
now a lot of it's getting aimed my way
by a kind of a category error because i
am an english major and a science
fiction writer and um that's all i am so
the shift from
if somebody is actually coming to me to
find
solutions for climate change then we're
in terrible trouble
um and it's worried me a lot um but i'm
beginning to see
things that i can do even as the
cardboard cutout
for the minister for the future and
that's been a bit of a comfort and i'll
tell you about that journey
for those of you who have read the book
it won't need explaining but i want to
for those of you who haven't it's um
the idea came from me came to me when i
was thinking
about this new information
that at wet bulb 35 temperatures human
beings will die
of hyperthermia that we aren't evolved
for it and it will be fatal even if you
were naked in the shade with a fan on
you hyperthermia would still kill you
within hours we just aren't set for it
and there had been a
a movement
ecomodernism or maybe just your ordinary
environmental humanities departments or
philosophy departments just saying
humans are so adaptable we'll just adapt
to whatever temperature happens although
of course we should try to mitigate but
since we're not going to do it we'll
just be ever so adaptable and this was
of course ignoring all of our cousins
species we rely on but it was also wrong
in that
vast swathes of the earth's surface
including
one of the highest wet bulb temperatures
ever was outside of chicago
so vast parts of the earth's surface
could become uninhabitable and suddenly
the 1.5 c
limit on temperature rise that had been
advised and got taken up as one of the
achievements of the glasgow
cop26
was beginning to look like
a necessary hard limit that we need to
adhere to one of several planetary
boundaries that we are plunging towards
in a trajectory that seems to say we're
going to be going past them
into um
toward a hot house earth status which in
the paleological past would mean almost
no ice on the planet at all etc in which
case we'd be seriously underwater here
um
i needed to write that and that's why
the first scene of the novel is in india
in one of these heatwave events and as a
shocking experience i know it was hard
to write it's hard to read and then
after that
a best-case scenario
um
with that kind of a situation that we're
in in the 2020s i wanted to portray
30 years
going in
into
a utopian space with utopia defined as
this
we dodge the mass extinction event
because everything else is recoverable
so the bar is quite lowered compared to
the perfect society of old
but um it would be a mighty achievement
if we were to indeed to dodge a mass
extinction event in the 21st century
given where we are and where we're going
so um this was the goal in my novel
i wanted it to
look and feel messy so that when you
were reading it you could suspend your
disbelief in classic coloridian style
you could um
this the willing suspension of disbelief
is the the joy of every reader of novels
lives and i began as a reader before as
a writer that's for sure
you read it you believe it and then you
come out it afterwards and you evaluate
it so to believe a positive feature from
where we are now i had to include
a lot of the bad stuff too and i noticed
now looking back at it
a lot of things i didn't notice while i
was writing it which i have to say was
about
six to eight months in 2019
a much darker time than now i have to
add because it wasn't clear that trump
would not win and also the pandemic
hadn't happened yet and so it looked
like we were gonna slouch mindlessly
sleepwalk off the cliff
um and in many ways the pandemic was a
slap in the face that speeded everything
up for both
ill and for good
so in 2019 i was in a darker space and
so the dark stuff in ministry for the
future is quite dark indeed and i
wouldn't want to
have anybody take this book to be an
instruction manual as to how to behave
uh given the various murders and
shooting planes out of the sky that
occur in the course of that particular
history
looking at it later i saw that for every
time something positive happened there
would be a reversal there were three
kinds of death and there's murder
illness and accident um some major
characters there's
um a sense that
of uh
desperate chaos that nobody's in control
and everything in other words that is
inevitably going to be the case
in the 2020s i wanted to represent in
that way and yet still show
a sequence of events that would get us
to a point like 30 years out although
now i would say the timeline is
completely wrong
and that everything that i talked about
happening in 30 years
needs to happen and will happen in about
10 years which is a shocking
acceleration but i think it's true
so i had
[Applause]
you know
a novel about heat death he he
he waved death of millions of people and
then how to techno um
you know political economy finance it
really sounds quite awful i mean doesn't
it as a novel reader it's like castor
oil it's already i had a reputation for
being the castor oil of science fiction
literature you know it's good for you
but you you're going to have to choke
hold your nose as you as you down this
stuff um
a novel needs to be fun and so like in
new york 2140 perhaps they're having a
little bit too much fun in a world with
sea level rise 50 feet higher that was a
different time and a different kind of a
novel a comedy of coping i quite love
that book it is more fun but ministry
for the future had to have its own fun
and that could be in the play of forms
so it hangs on a regular novel that's
maybe novella length um mary murphy and
frank may the two central characters and
then their shadow badim
these for a long novel the ordinary
characters in it are just quite few
but on to that i also hung
uh everything wikipedia articles meeting
notes and i had dramatized enough
meetings that when i discovered you
could just include the notes this is a
marvelous discovery
nobody had to go through another meeting
in a room which in green earth is a a
long slog
through the dc uh wilderness
um
also it narratives this was something
from the 18th century it was a little
fad when printing and reading came out
in england the it narrative would be the
story of a coin it would go from pocket
to pocket or a violin
and being the 18th century it would
usually go through somebody's digestive
tract and get [ __ ] out and it was all
very exciting except for uh protagonists
without agency
there's a reason the narrative died very
quickly and
i discovered that in writing just a
couple for this book a carbon atom the
market that kind of thing a photon
also riddles anglo-saxon literature
about one-third of what remains of
anglo-saxon is is riddles and mostly
these look to be puns it's quite funny
these scholars can't tell one riddle
from anglo-saxon the answer is either a
an angel or a grasshopper and and
usually they're double entendres of a
sexual nature also um so you can see
that the games that are being played
around the the fire in the in the barrow
houses of the anglo-saxon times i used
those
many other forms dialogues radio radio
transcripts and then the eyewitness
account this was the crucial thing it's
one of the things that
made this
book
its impact in my opinion it sure did for
me as a writer an eyewitness account is
not the same
as ordinary novelization you don't talk
you don't set the scene you don't talk
about eating breakfast you don't
live it they call it dramatization for a
very good reason as if in your mind
you're seeing it staged in real time
with all of its details like drama
well an eyewitness account they're
usually interviewing someone 10 to 20
years later that person is talking about
what happened in a propulsive rush of
memory
and they're judging it judging
themselves and why that why they're
being interviewed what that did in
history and what it did to their lives
as a modality the eyewitness account is
an awesome thing and i began to collect
collections of them
um spring 1945 in germany
may 1968 and in paris
these collections are uh stunning and
some of them the ancient world the whole
of history usually the bigger the
stretch of the history being eyewitness
accounted the the weaker the anthology
but
they're all worth looking at and i might
never write anything else again but a
whole bunch of fictionalized eyewitness
accounts because it was like uh
channeling voices in a way that a
novelist always wants but someone gets
sit down
be prepped
take a refugee camp or a riot at a train
station or or a fishing boat being taken
over by pirates from other pirates
a city running out of water um
like cape town maybe um and these
should have been and were five pages or
less and the book is stuffed with them
and
that i think the sense of world history
and multiplicity
it felt right and and it's probably one
of the keys to the book along with
uh the carbon coin which i'll get to
later and the um the sense of chaos and
disorder that the all the forms together
do
there's one more thing that i did that i
didn't realize till afterwards i would
divide science fiction up temporally
there's um far future science fiction
which we would call space opera people
are zipping around the galaxy star wars
star trek space opera people know what
it is but it's a form of fantasy as i
tried to show in my novel aurora but
it's a great
story space there's no no knock against
space opera not when ian banks and gene
wolf have written that
ken mccloud
there's great space opera it's not
normally what i do in fact i think i've
only tried it once or twice
but it's out there and a lot of people
when you say science fiction they're
thinking just that but there's also near
future science fiction and those of you
sometimes you'll see neil stephenson do
it william gibson day after tomorrow
it's very common in science fiction that
the present is is presented
as a few years
pushed down the line with some classic
sf extrapolation of trends to show what
seems interesting and now it's a form of
realism to write now and reads as such
it's better realism than literary
fiction is with without a doubt
and that's a
a big part of why science fiction has an
impact in the world
then there's the middle zone
relatively deep populate
what i call it future history a century
out two centuries out three centuries
out
if you think about it you're not going
to find too many science fiction
classics that fit that song but if you
think about my career the mars trilogy
new york 2140 that's the year
2312 that's the year
it goes on like that
although i'm forgetting my own
bibliography right now but um that is a
zone i find of interest called future
history where you actually see not just
what will happen with the present pushed
but what kind of historical change is
possible from where we are right now and
can you articulate it on the page in a
way that the reader can say oh my gosh
in 2312 i could be living on the moons
of jupiter and um visiting earth it
would be a wreck and they'd be fighting
sea level rise and then never would have
gotten out of there their poor old
poverty traps had old earth i think i
called it and and this is 300 years out
and you can say well yeah and it could
happen no laws of physics are broken
it's not space opera there's a history
that runs back to now
super interesting thing
well in ministry for the future without
planning it what i think i did by
accident was to
take future history where history really
has happened and i jammed it into the
near future science fiction moment so
stuff that i used to write about
happening 200 years from now i said look
it's happening in the year 2035 or it's
starting right now and will immediately
and this i think was like putting
together you know like let's see what
happens when we put together some
uranium with a little explosive force
it blew up in my face and and i've been
uh blown up ever since
so i think this is what happened there
so um
it got me it got me invited to cop 26
one of many rather astonishing
invitations over the last year and a
half i was
feeling surprised and then more
surprised and then after a while i
thought
either i'm not surprised anymore or else
i'm permanently surprised which is a
great state of consciousness to be and
we all should be wandering around going
i just can't believe it this is a
this is amazing because it is
and for me it has gone from pillar to
post and an invitation from actually i
will tell this story on myself
i was at um
glasgow inside the blue zone my hangout
was the un futures lab when they were my
home base my my buddies they took care
of me and they gave me a closet to sleep
in if i had to take a nap and they
taught me things well there and it was
in tremendous education and at one point
my my main host a woman named coco
warner has worked at every one of the
cops for the u.n she said stan
who invited you here
and i thought it was her
and i was looking at her going oh my god
i don't know anything i don't even know
why i'm here
and i had to investigate i had to
pretend i looked there and i said
um well the invocation came from nigel
topping whose official title was the
high champion for crop 26 is the british
government likes their titles a lot
the high champion was his official title
good guy and he was the one who invited
me and he gave me a red pass which meant
that in the blue zone i could go
anywhere i wanted
and this wasn't true for most people who
are observers you would get a yellow
badge and you wouldn't go into the
negotiating sessions that was for people
with red or blue and blue was just the
u.n itself
so there i was with this red badge which
nigel topping had given me
and i decided that the rest of the thing
being i'm kind of a trade show for each
nation would buy a pavilion in a giant
convention center and i i don't know if
you all have seen pictures of the blue
zone in a cop but it's somewhat like a
trade show or a circus or a
um
it's or a science fiction convention and
anybody who knows science fiction
conventions uh one of those for two days
is not bad for two weeks you have got to
be kidding me
um and yet
so i began to go to negotiating sessions
any kind of negotiating session and this
is very interesting
they were more than 50 women in their
30s and 40s lawyers diplomats scientists
they were working a document they were
editing together they were revising
editing
proposing
in the this is one kind of session
anyway document editing um by a
ferociously concentrated cheerful but
meticulous
um
for my point of view young women
and with some elderly brit diplomats who
were staggering around with a limp and a
breeze case from bretton woods and it
was it was very cute how calm they were
compared to
everybody else there
and
i was impressed by that and
then in other negotiating sessions in in
very polite tones of voice people were
arguing over money
and the developed world was holding back
their bags of money and the developing
world was saying you promised it and we
need it and in polite voices you were
seeing the incredible tight-fistedness
the self-destructive tight-fistedness of
all of the developed countries who had
promised money in the paris agreement
and aren't coughing it up
one of the developing nations diplomats
said to me that
the sewage budget for new york city is
35 billion dollars a year and the
developed world has just given us 20
billion when they promised 100 billion
and even 100 billion is
not enough but 20 billion is ridiculous
and that's where they were at so this
was a depressing part of glasgow for
sure but to see it all happen real time
i began to understand
cop is just a place to come and look at
each other on an annual basis to see
what we're doing
in the rest of the world the rest of the
year it is not the place of solving
problems
it's there's no legally binding treaties
there and there's no sheriff nor a jail
if you were to break the promises or
even to leave the agreement outright
it has some beautiful mechanisms in it
it has an injunction to permanently
improve each time they meet everybody's
supposed to up their promises and make
things better and so it's like a ratchet
or a come along
each year you ratchet up the
intensity of the promises but their
promises only and i began to think
it's like a marriage
this is what you got to think of it as
you promised to spend your whole life
together and to do productive things
together
five years later you break up nobody
throws you in jail
um hopefully and and so what you've got
at this point is a world in which all
the nation states
have in effect joined into
a group marriage or something like a
marriage a set of promises to behave in
certain ways together
and there's no place to move if you get
a divorce it's like one of those
stories from my my my soviet agent
during the ussr days he and his wife had
divorced 10 years before but they were
still in the same apartment well the
world's going to be like that we can't
get away from each other and there's we
got i'm going to come back to talking
about the nation-state system
so
i'm
everybody i guess the last things i
would say about cop well there's a few
observations
it was a militarized site so the uk
government was really worried because of
world leaders coming or because of
seattle 1999
it was behind barbed wire and tank
stoppers the it was on the river clyde
so that there were zodiacs out on the
river with um military people and
machine guns there were helicopters just
hovering oftentimes especially during
the marches
and the scottish people were loving
their marches
i stood next to bill mckibben as the
start of one march we were like at the
parade marshals you know off you go off
you go and they were seeing mckibben
who's very recognizable going oh my god
you know it's saint bill is blessing
this march
and they had taken their kids out of
school out of preschool it was a family
affair everybody had made banners and
posters it's quite beautiful um
ten thousand people on friday a hundred
thousand people on saturday and about a
hundred people in us in a non-sanctioned
march where there were many more police
than there were marchers and i joined
all three of them
um but i have to admit that the big one
on saturday i only enjoined him because
i needed to cross the street and there
was no other way and so i went out there
and i joined a group of nurses and we
chatted for a while and i flowed
downstream for about 100 yards or so and
then got off on the other side and went
my way
um but it was quite beautiful to see the
civic engagement of the scottish people
with uh being the host of cop
and then
the results from it
were good as far as they go
but every diplomat and scientists there
the more they knew about the cop system
in the world the more scared they were
because although it is an admirable
system and way better than nothing at
all it's too slow because it's built on
a consensus model every nation there has
to agree to every sentence
you saw an example of this in the last
hours where they were going to phase out
coal and at the last moment in china and
india and several other nations said um
um oh gosh we can't do that um we we
refuse and they went into a huddle and
overtime
a couple hours of intense lobby and they
came out well we'll face down call and
then everybody signed off on it well
this kind of consensus model although
admirable it's like the general assembly
without the security council so it's a
true
international body of nations where
you've got i want to talk about this a
bit more later also from the nation
state
to the member state a very important
distinction
you've got all the people there but
since they have to all agree to every
statement
um as admirable as it is it's too slow
compared to the crisis i reckoned on the
train ride down to london that if we had
is such a guess but it's a science
fiction exercise if we had 40 years
the cop
procedures might work but we only have
10.
so they're not enough and we're and and
we and i left cop thinking we are in
terrible trouble and nothing in the four
months since then has made me change my
mind on that we are in terrible trouble
but that doesn't mean
what that means also needs to be
unpacked
um
[Music]
in the months since then i thought it
would slack off it didn't slack off
and i began to
get quite nervous about being helpless
to suggest or say anything but what i
began to realize is i could take
somebody um
who were was interested in talking to me
about topic x
and i could connect them up with
somebody else who was an expert on topic
x
and they didn't know about each other
because the world is too big and that's
interesting in and of itself that
although there's lots of good work being
done
not only is there no coordinating force
that's making priorities and and linking
things up together and all that but
that's almost impossible in the in the
world that we're in who would do that
i'm involved with the un's 50-year
forecasting group and the un is doing
their damnedest to maybe rate and
prioritize
they're overwhelmed they can't do it you
would have to
postulate a a ministry for the future
that was a really good budget
and a huge team of people trying to sort
and connect and that doesn't really
exist but as my cardboard cutout
imitation of a minister i can now begin
to connect people who should know about
each other just recently
i met the woman who runs california's 30
by 30 program 30 of california protected
land for wild creatures by the year 2030
amazing idea and i thought it would
never happen in my lifetime and already
they're shooting for 2030 and and they
say well after we hit 30 by 30 we're
going to shoot for 50 by 50 and then
we'll have a healthy biosphere
and california is an exemplary space as
you know and teaches the rest of the
world how to do these things and the
rest of the world teaches california
it's a super promising thing but she had
never met the head of the pacific
conservation league
which without this 30 by 30 framework
had nevertheless been working on similar
causes for the last
25 years
and i was able to say oh gosh you need
you know you're both in the sacramento
area need to meet they've since met it's
a productive meeting things will go on
uh it's been a pleasure for me and when
i was talking with this jennifer norris
head of 30 by 30 what we began to
discover together
is you need
the framework tail the frame tail
because everybody's individual efforts
are going to be too small to matter or
to change the world and you do what you
can and you're thinking well i'm i'm
swimming again i'm crossing the
pacific by swimming i'm in terrible
trouble here
because it's such a small drop in the
bucket or drop in the ocean
but if you see that
you're part of a larger story where
everybody else is also putting say
another analogy a brick in the wall you
work on your brick you know there's a
wall you'll stick your brick into it
this is a crucial realization for
keeping spirits up solidarity mutual aid
and it's funny when you think about this
wall analogy for one thing i build my
walls in maine out of glacial cobble
it's the worst possible rock to make
walls out of hilariously bad and every
every spring i go out there with my wife
and find my last year's wall has fallen
down just from the freezing thaw cycle
um and gravity
and that's the kind of material we have
right and also there's no architect and
there's no stone mason but nevertheless
this is how um
group
projects work
everybody knows what needs to be built
and so you just put your brick in the
wall and to feel that the concept of the
wall is helping so i think that that's
another reason why ministry for the
future has had people had a hunger for
that story that if everything that is
possibly be done gets done then even the
bad stuff won't be able to stop us from
getting to a good place now this is a
proposition not us obviously it's a it's
a science fiction story a utopian one
when i say that
uh i don't know if it's true and nobody
else knows either
i'm going to come to a close
soon but i want to talk about a few
things before i do
the accelerated timeline everything's
going faster partly because of the
pandemic partly because no one person
can do the research to figure out where
the cutting edge is on all these things
so i was talking about a carbon coin and
i thought this was the idea of one guy
adult and chen in fact the network for
greening the financial system as an
organization of 89 central banks exactly
the people you want working on it and
they are working on it um the glacier
geo engineering which i thought had been
an idea slipped to me by a single
glaciologist it's got really good papers
on it in science and now in science
direct in nature in science direct
um there are new geoengineering methods
that are less intrusive and more active
than more
effective than solar radiation
management that are being talked about
all the time and 30 by 30 as i mentioned
when i read the eo wilson book half
earth i thought well this is utopian
science fiction indeed this will never
happen and now we're already on the way
to it and that was only 15 years ago so
in this excel we're in a moment of
accelerated danger and there's also an
accelerated response
so you can't
freak out
i say this to myself um
one time i want to tell you about
freakouts
i was in the swiss alps i had crossed a
pass i sat down on a point looking down
at a
at a reservoir down below me and i saw a
helicopter coming up there was a little
hud underneath me it was closed it was
locked it had no signs on it
and um
it was irrelevant and i thought that
this helicopter rising up through the
air was going to land at a swiss alpine
hut i could see in the distance and
resupply it which i'd seen before
and it came up and it was facing me
and i was looking at the operator and
thinking why why is he here it was
really loud and i was looking right
through the bubble at the pilot and he
tilted in towards me and i be i got up i
turned around i went on to the flat
behind where i had been sitting
and he was i he was coming at me he was
coming at me he was going to kill me i
was in a horror movie i freaked out i
turned around and i ran up the hill like
a bunny like you see bunnies run when
they know that they're doomed i just
turned and i ran and i turned around
again thinking oh god this is so bad
and he was he needed to land on that
spot where i was sitting and he had no
way to tell me that i said ah yes i i'm
not in a horror movie after all you know
and i walked down the hillside
to talk to him about it
and i said geez i'm sorry about you know
sitting on your landing spot i just
didn't know and he looked at me and goes
really loud
and i realized that
helicopter blades as they're slowing
down
they become visible from the inside out
and what i thought was the end of the
helicopter blade was about halfway out
and there was a blur that i hadn't quite
noticed and i and and i was coming
downhill and the
rotors were
were drooping as they slowed down
i was literally 15 feet away from having
decapitated myself
so i i just gave up on talking to the
guy i took i went for the
the the swiss alpine huts have a thing
called cafe fertig coffee finished which
is coffee filled with brandy and i was
going to go get a cafe fair tag and
finish myself up and i had a the
sandwich that i'd been eating when this
whole adventure started was just
squished in my hand to the rib of dough
rib dough as eating this dough thinking
dang how could have i explained to lisa
that i had died in a helicopter
accident by walking into the blades
but i bring up this story because we are
going to be having freakouts like that
what you know russia suddenly invades
the ukraine um and it's a disaster
especially for the ukrainians and for
the rest of the world you get this ipcc
report the one that really
is the most frightening yet as they all
are it's news it should be the top news
in everybody's feed every day for the
next
forever and it's buried by a war and we
don't know what's going to happen next
and these kind of freakouts are going to
keep happening as we go on and even the
war is a um
is a result of a country that is a petro
state all the petro states are in
terrible trouble because they um get 60
to 80 percent of their national income
from selling fossil fuels which
supposedly is a stranded asset and
should go away since they signed the
paris agreement and you don't want to
cook the planet
well they're on the horns of a dilemma
with no
way out they're looking down the barrel
of a gun
save your country from complete
bankruptcy and social collapse become a
failed state or else keep burning in and
torch down the world and we're all in
the same boat
some petro states are going to choose
one and some of the other but we need
and people are right now talking about
exit ramps for putin
we need exit ramps for the petro states
because it's about a third of the
world's population that lives in petro
states and they have no
way to not be bankrupt so the carbon
coin is a great idea you draw down a ton
of co2
and you get paid a carbon coin and it's
worth more in fiat currency this is not
a cryptocurrency it's a fiat currency
backed by the central banks
and
um
you get paid more you make more by
drawing down carbon than it costs you to
do that operation and you get paid for
doing the right thing rather than the
wrong thing carbon coin is i think the
central banks are already uh discussing
it it's a it could happen it's carbon
quantitative easing and sometimes called
real obvious idea but compensating the
petrol states and here's where i'm going
to end we're going to have to do it or
else we have a failed states all over
the world and the world
falls into disorder and they go ahead
and drag their heels and burn their
fossil fuels in a desperate attempt to
stay solvent financially this has to be
addressed where are our economists where
are our
political economists in this world we
need that worked out i would say this
the payments you got to go to the petrol
states and say look we'll pay you to
keep it in the ground
the payments have to be amortized so
we'll you'll get payments over the next
century just like as if you were selling
the oil or coal or natural gas it will
be discounted wall street puts it this
way you got to take a haircut
you won't get the full value but you'll
get enough that you'll take the deal you
get it discounted and the discount rate
would be real interesting should it
maybe be a bathtub curve you get a lot
of payments then you don't then you get
more later as a reward i mean here's
where the economists and people who like
to do gamification of human um
motivation
need to get into that game and work the
discount rates
and then it has to be entailed the money
can't be given to kleptocrats on
autocrats and just banked away somewhere
else it needs to be spent on
decarbonization and that is an
imposition on national sovereignty so
there'll be squawks on all sides for
this deal the petro states will say look
we are a nation state we have
sovereignty if you're going to give us
money great but we get to do with what
we want because you you don't get to
impose on us
at that point
the people offering to give the money
are going to have to say no that isn't
how this one works
and there you go from the nation-state
to the member state and member states
have a different
relationship to sovereignty legally and
emotionally than than nation states used
to so the west failing system has to
shift
and maybe finance can drive it
into member states and all the european
nations are now member states of the
european union all the nations on earth
are members of the paris agreement so in
effect we are already supposedly member
states but of course the big bad boys on
the planet the the giant powers like the
united states and china
and now russia they don't want to think
of themselves as member states that are
beholden to anybody else sovereignty
still rules but the petro states might
be desperate enough to decide we are now
going to sign the fossil fuel
non-proliferation treaty or there's
going to be a mechanism that's part of
cop part of the paris agreement
where the the compensatory mechanisms
for
judging how much fossil fuel they have
and how much they get paid get worked
out in a big international agreement and
what i saw at cop26 it shows me that
will be enormously difficult but it's
better than crashing human civilization
so
um that maybe that's a good ending point
better than crashing civilization we pay
off the petrol states we compensate them
we try to keep the whole thing going
in a collaborative manner we become
member states of a larger unity and and
we scrape through without the mass
extinction event hopefully yeah all in
there
i better
[Music]
[Applause]
stan that was just fantastic
and always always a pleasure to see you
and to get the chance to chat with you
um
stan i just want to say before we start
i mean you you talk about yourself as oh
i'm in i'm an english major i write
science fiction and so on but i think
what you really are initially a
fantastic writer is you're a philosopher
like in your sci-fi you are
philosophizing about the future and how
we how we build that future in a way
that uh sci-fi that is
smaller in scope doesn't really do so
well i appreciate what you are
suggesting by that but i want to
i'm a science fiction patriot
i want to say that this is simply what
science fiction should always be doing
so that's the way i would put it is this
is what science fiction can do
related to that one of the things that i
think is most interesting about you as a
science fiction author and also as a
climate activist is you see a lot of
a lot of climate activism that is very
sort of naturalist and as opposed to
a more
aggressive and ambitious interventions
and in in your books in in
ministry for the future but also in in
the mars series in the previous uh
science in the capital series in 2012
you are very willing to go to a real
focus on solutions that are epic in
scale that are massive human endeavors
where does that come from for you it
comes from stuart
now
we are a technological species we were
technological before we were human we
co-evolved with tools fire
stones etc so
maybe this is also part of being a
science fiction writer i believe in
technology
but also justice is a technology
language is a technology it's a big word
it's what we do and now we're in a
desperate straits so i've been thinking
all hands on deck
really we ought to keep nuclear plants
going as a bridge technology to cleaner
cleaner
maybe we might have to do some
modifications that people call
geoengineering we need to talk about
that a little more because there's so
many variants going on
but uh
and i'm you know me i mean many of you
do uh old hippie leftist
an american green
an eco-marxist american leftist although
marxist is really the wrong word and
eco leftist
the wobblies over parties
you know my angle and from that angle i
say
tech
um anything whatever works except for
fascism which wouldn't work anyway but
um but all of the things that we might
try we have to try see what works and
and
dodge the mass extinction event and then
solve the outstanding problems
fantastic well said
um
stan on the topic of technology that
works and geoengineering a couple
different people in the audience sarah
schubert uh and paul baumgardt hi paul
have asked about what are these
geoengineering technologies you see as
effective but maybe less intrusive than
solar radiation management okay well
thanks i'm and i only know this
because of the last couple of months
running into sir david king um
the brit who was environmental minister
to blair and brown
sir dave is working on this at cambridge
university and i'm hearing things i've
never heard before
you remember iron filings dropped in the
ocean to create algal blooms that die
and sink to the bottom and the oceans
are already so sick everybody thinks
that idea with a shudder of horror and
sir dave said yeah of course it
shouldn't be iron filings it should be
whale poop
i'm thinking what he goes well there's
only one percent of the whales that
there used to be they eat low they poop
high
this is sir dave in a british accent
saying this exact stuff to me it's a bio
pump it helps everything you have more
fish you have healthier oceans it it it
begins to even
reduce the acidity it's like the perfect
solution we're going to send ships all
around the oceans
and we're going to have an artificially
mixed like giant oil tankers full of
artificially mixed whale poop jump drop
it overboard in a way that a whale pod
would and it'll even bring whales back
and then they can do it themselves well
i've never heard of that before i'm
thinking
well what's the harm in it like what
will it hurt
um another one they said and this one
maybe is more well known the arctic ice
is melting the sea ice the less and less
were terrible trouble up there in the
arctic worse than anywhere else
a lot of boats and he said automatic
boats like this new mayflower but i
think they could be crude why not be fun
shooting a very fine spray of salt water
so that there are salt crystals in it
just above the cloud layer and it
whitens and thickens the clouds and you
have a better situation in the arctic
and it's not particularly
like solar radiation management's global
monstrous thing
and then the thing that's in my book the
pulling the ice out from under the big
glaciers in antarctica to slow them down
that could be done oil industry navies
of the world
my next column in bloomberg green will
be precisely about this plan
and you think well that's so crazy no
one will ever do it but people do like
sea level they like the beaches they
like their coastal towns
and the fact that we could maybe we have
10 to 20 years to to stop the the
irrevocable
massive rise of sea levels such that we
would be
um
really and truly this room would be
underwater all right up to the ceiling
in certain scenarios pretty damn fast
so that these kind of these are the
things these are the kind of and there
are more of them of course you know on
the flip side i did hear that you could
buy
land at nevada prices it'll one day be
beach front value
yeah but it would be such crappy beaches
compared to our beloved sand beaches
this is why in new york 2140 and i think
in
aurora
people are dredging old beach sand out
of the shallows and reestablishing
beaches on higher sea level because i
want my beaches
kevin kelly asks are there other
discoveries or inventions outside of
sort of the geo engineering space that
you think are underrated or
underappreciated today
well i
i'm behind the curve on this um i i
stagger around i i would say nature
briefing science news society for
environmental journalists
and the american geophysical unions
magazine eos these four things can
keep you scientifically literate uh at a
pace you can actually sustain
just recently i read about these deep
water pumps you just pump cold water
from it works best in the tropics if
there's a 20 degree centigrade
differential between the water deep down
and the water on the surface you can get
about a two or three percent
um efficiency rating of electricity out
of the hot cold water running a turbine
they warned us that if once you build 15
000 of these plants you might actually
change the temperature of the ocean in
ways that made it work less well
thinking okay we'll build 14 000
whatever
i thought that was rather exciting
because these island nations that are
already sinking they have to ship in
diesel at enormous expense and if they
had even one of these plants on their
island that island would be have enough
kilowattage to
supply all their needs and it's pretty
clean
they actually and you have little
lobster
industries
at the top of these cold pumps because
it's cold water in the tropics so
they're growing lobsters i mean it's
very funny there is a comic level to it
and i believe stewart has always been
very attuned to this there's a comic
aspect to our adjustment to the world
technologically and even though we're
under ferocious pressure
and it all could go crash and boom um
it still has a somewhat to me
it's it's like well maybe it's like
laurel and hardy or one of these
horrible keystone cops things i mean
it's funny to see people in desperate
danger
sometimes it is um
you talk a lot about economics in the
book like a lot of the book is really
not just carbon coin but other things
yeah one of the things you talk about
and a listener called uh paul has asked
a question into this is the discount
rate and how that changes our calculus
of investing to to save the future and i
didn't hear you talk about it in the
talk do you want to riff on that sure
i'll try to be brief particularly since
we're hitting the the borders of my
comprehension but and a lot of you will
know more than i do the discount rate
when you're making an economic
calculation about how much you should
spend in the present to benefit the
future if you if they have the same
since the future goes out forever if
their
needs are equal to ours then our we
should be spending everything for the
people of the future and not for
ourselves so a discount rate is
introduced and william nordhaus won a
pseudo nobel prize for saying the
discount rate could be four percent well
this is just a robbery of the
generations of the future it's way too
high and there are some people arguing
it should be flat um some very good
economist some argue it should maybe be
curvaceous and start flat and then
discount so you don't get infinities in
your calculations other people argue the
opposite you could have a high discount
rate and as you run into the future
calculations you go to zero
well this is beyond me but it certainly
should be a big topic of conversation
because the future gets ponzi schemed
when the discount rate is too high and
who would who would make a decision on
that or how would that get determined or
how that would affect what's happening
okay but well this is a modeling
exercise economists so neoliberal
economists would say
let the market do it and
we'll just let the group mind and the
algorithms the the ais
all this fear of super ai i mean kevin
is very reassuring about this in ways
that are important to me but if you give
over the ai over to ai to algorithms
your financial calculations in modeling
you can indeed just dial it yourself and
begin to tell
business leaders and government leaders
and we should talk about private capital
too
um the discount rate needs to be
um
zero and then shading up to
two uh when you get to people that are
200 years out in order to make your
calculations work see what that does
they should be played with like a dial
effectively it's a it's an ethical dial
it's a moral dial how much do you value
the lives to come after us and to be
able to put a number on that is of
course the great achievement of
economics if it is great let's stay on
economics for a bit so you mentioned ai
and this is the second novel after 2312
where you've posited that instead of
using the market to determine a resource
allocation that uh ai i think was
quantum ai in 2312 and ai in this case
might be powerful enough to actually be
able to do
uh rational and effective sort of
economy optimization or resource
allocation and not depend on markets as
we have now
yeah i have no idea
yeah
this is where my english major hood um i
would refer you to uh francis bufford's
book red plenty where about the soviet
union computer scientist trying to
invent computers strong enough to run a
centralized economy by planning alone
without a market in time to avoid the
crash of the soviet union and you know
the end of that story but what a fine
novel and discussions of it online go
into the technical aspects of this in
ways i can't follow um
and also it's still going to be coming
back to humans dialing it in we will be
writing the algorithms the ai's will
then be making the calculations like how
many shoes does the human race need
well eight billion times two you know
it's not that hard so uh my feeling is
it's still a human calculation
ultimately fair enough uh you mentioned
private capital so i know that in the
audience right now we have a number of
people who are uh climate entrepreneurs
uh or uh climate investors or somehow in
the private sector related to climate
energy raise your hands if you're if
you're one of those people out here so
you've got a number i think oh i love
you i know yeah um so what's your view
like you you're just talking about sort
of your your interesting structure
you're this great passage for your
first person narrative of the market
talking about like what it's done and
how it's eaten everything um what is
your view of like the role of private
enterprise private capital startups
and the market i i don't like the market
it's a it's an over simple algorithm
we give our decisions over to it and say
that they're crowdsourced but in fact
it's predatory
um the algorithm is written in with too
many externalities and it's not like two
people going down to barter i'll give
you my ox if you give me a loaf of bread
that is not what a market is anymore
it's simply a
a systemic uh extraction of value from
from working people this is classic
leftist theory and i'm totally in favor
of government over market that
essentially at this point we're like in
world war ii when government seized the
marketplace and private industries and
said look to win this war you're doing
what we say it's a planned economy u.s
britain keynes was a big theorist to
this and we won the war in a completely
planned economy like give us all your 10
right now that kind of thing and yet
we're in a similarly existential crisis
here where i do think governments have
to take over
but however
we're in a global capitalist system
we've only got 10 years and what i want
theoretically
is not going to come to pass
by a waving of the wand or by a thought
exercise we're in the world we're in and
what i'm observing is
chinese central bank has about
five trillion dollars in assets um us
for the eu about three this is what they
keep in the house in order to deal with
crises
private capital has well mark cronie
could gather um 130 trillion dollars in
assets that all promise to be green
and what i'm saying is that the central
banks have
printed tons of money in the last couple
of quantitative easings that
capitalism being what it is in this late
monopoly stage the rich have seized it
all this because it's a kind of a vacuum
suck that the more money you have the
more you can grab out of a system like
the one we're in so all the qe money has
not gone to the bottom 50 of the
populace but has gone to the top there's
tons of money and people are looking at
weird things like maybe i'll buy some
bitcoin and then i can sell before it
pops
that kind of excess cash lots of and
also lots of earnings of real businesses
of things that people really wanted as
well
and there's a lot of it and it's being
aggregated into asset managers so when i
wrote new york 2140 it was hedge fund
managers they were after their alpha
they were simply playing the game in
order to make lots of money for
investors that could afford to be take
risks and if they lost it it didn't
matter because it was just a pocket
change to them so you would try your
alpha was how much more percent you got
per year than the ordinary rate of
having a savings account or whatever the
average was so that was a ugly game
michael lewis exposed that game often
the big short liars poker but now it's
different i saw this in glasgow there
was lots of private capital coming there
going how can we green the world fast
enough to avoid catastrophe by investing
and maybe it isn't the highest rate of
return but it's this
rightist rate of return the the
they're going long on the world because
when the world crashes it's bad for
business
and so
but there's so much capital that
and there are asset managers now that
are dealing with stupendous amounts i
mean larry fink of blackrock was at
glasgow in fact i ate his um excess
pizza i sat down and i was starving i
said can i have this pizza and my
chinese friend head of chinese world
wildlife fan said you sure can you're
eating larry thinks
leftovers i was starving um so but he
stands with a metaphor in that yeah
the science fiction writer is always
starving
um
but i saw it over and over again i i was
meeting with groups anybody who asked me
to come talk i would try to understand
what their angle was
and try to encourage them it was just
what i felt my role was i had 38
engagements in 12 days
and i just talked my brains out i
actually lost my voice and i had to talk
anyway
a very creaky voice by the end
i forged on and what i saw were groups
that wanted to go green it was more
important to grow green than to max your
alpha and this i think is maybe a sign
of being scared but also of
having the right values at last
so um
you know there'll be post-capitalism one
day but right now what we need is green
capitalism and government intervention
big time and the two together are both
crucially necessary
so a couple directions go to that um
robbie nicholson is a climate
entrepreneur trying to change banking uh
asks what's the most surprising impact
that's come out of the ministry
or maybe what's the most surprising of
these invitations that you got at cop
there's a clear winner there i'm off to
do a conference with the dalai lama next
month
um so i would say that one
i thought i was beyond surprised but um
yeah that one is the clear winner
okay
i mean i'm a long now hometown guy i
mean i love long now but the dalai lama
has been a big part of my mental life
for
for um decades and he's 87 and he's um
he's the great guy so it's going to be
fun
and it's in his town you know or
dharamsala the town that the indian
government that nehru gave him to be an
exile in in the in the himalayan
foothills the rhododendrons will be out
and i know i shouldn't be uh selfish
about this but um
i never thought i'd see the himalayas
again even from the foothills or the air
and now i'm going to just to do this one
trip that's amazing and well deserved
um
one more one more finance question move
on other topics uh carol block uh writes
you know we're looking at the russian
invasion of ukraine and one may be
surprising things happen as far as the
opaqueness of the financial world is is
that the swiss have dropped neutrality
and are unmasking these russian accounts
and so they will not be a clearinghouse
for private uh hidden uh russian wealth
yeah does that give you hope about a
future of increased transparency that
might help in this
maybe
it is a um it is the swiss dealing with
their dark past of being the bag man for
the criminals of the world and becoming
a wealthy little country that is just
entirely 65 percent a vertical mountain
range of
great beauty but low utility
and yet being extremely rich by being
the bag man these secret accounts and of
course there's the nazi gold there's the
jewish gold it is a dark past and a lot
of swiss are really um they repress it
but they're not proud of it so at this
point maybe they're trying to make a
break and and come clean at last and now
all money is digital and it occurs to me
that although i don't believe in
cryptocurrencies whatsoever i don't see
money has
it's a medium exchange it's a storage of
value and it's a sign of social trust
and cryptocurrencies have failed all
three of these tests of money so i'm a
believer in fiat money
but and the swiss
are they've got a solid part of that and
all money is now digital i wonder if it
could be trackable you don't need
blockchain blockchain is peculiar it
could be cryptography it could be a
different system it might quickly be
quantum
and then you would know where many was
you would know if it was legal or in a
tax haven i mean this gets to be
i am talking about as a statist here
like anarchists libertarians going you
got to be kidding me i mean we need to
be able to hide our money the state will
be in control
right now i want the states in control i
swear to god it's the only way we're
going to solve climate change that is
not an anarchist project that is a state
project but it needs to be member states
not sovereign states so um in that
larger picture money is important you
can't
let money slip away
into pockets where bad actors get to
continue with it at least that's my
theory you got to kill tax havens
actually taxes are a stupendously
interesting and powerful tool
for for doing good things
fantastic um
with a relationship with state actors
and other actors as you said there's
some dark passages in ministry for the
future and one of them is climate
terrorism
sarah schubert asks why do you think we
haven't seen climate terrorism or
violence directed at people that are
perceived as as climate criminals and do
you think there's something that will
happen in the future that will actually
change that i don't mean left because
i'm thinking of the fermi paradox you
know like why haven't we heard from
aliens and this is now called the
lanchester paradox from john lanchester
wonderful british writer good on money
good novelist and lanchester's paradox
is why aren't we seeing this stuff same
question as sarah's i don't know
um
mckibben
has been steadfast in saying
nothing works except for non-violent
resistance that
gathers the support of the
moderates in the middle and the ordinary
citizen when they see
people
in a disciplined way staying non-violent
doing civil resistance it garners their
support whereas even one bomb going off
or even extinction rebellion lying down
and blocking people on their way on
their way to work on the freeway you
gain more enemies than you gain
adherence so um this
rhetoric is the ancient greek art of
persuasion and it's worth studying a
rhetoric handbook because they had it
wired and it's a beautiful thing it's
one of the few things english majors
study that is useful and fun
um but there is no good rhetoric of
actions like and this is questions of
praxis what do you do to change power
into more healthy directions and
you have andreas malm how to blow up a
pipeline you got erica chenoweth why
civil resistance works you have mckibben
pointing to the effectiveness of a kind
of thorovian
almost a christian martin luther king
you know
lay down in front of the tanks take some
harm
and everybody's on your side because it
isn't fair
uh i'm not competent to discuss this
argument very well and the ministry for
the future is a mess it is not a book
you go to to sort these things out it
doesn't make a good distinction between
sabotage and murder for one thing and
badeem the guy who's doing things in the
black wing of the ministry for the
future
you have to decide what badim did in the
story
by judging what you would authorize if
you were body
so i cleverly snuck away from many um
statements of responsibility on what my
myself would support because i was too
squeamish about it i don't know i i
myself am a
pacifist
and you know um kind of vietnam era
pacifist and so i would not want to
recommend violence to any other people
that i wouldn't do myself it strikes me
as a very bad idea
and so i didn't but ministry was also
trying to be a realism
bad things are going to come down and if
if villages start being wiped out and
your entire family is killed and before
your eyes those people are going to be
angry not just for justice but for
vengeance
and so we may begin to see more of it
god knows i hope not it would uh it
would be better if the story of violence
compels people to act right before the
real violence comes into play and that's
one of the reasons i did what i did
stan i think something else we saw in
the book is other sorts of unilateral
actions in the book uh india takes it
upon themselves to engage in solar
radiation management geoengineering yeah
do you think we'll see
nations island nations anybody uh
engaging not only in solar radiation
management but in unilateral
pro-climate sorts of activities
well we certainly would have no moral
basis to object to it if they did there
isn't an international regime right now
they would not be breaking any laws
in in my novel someone objects to the
indian minister on the phone i thank my
mary murphy well that breaks the paris
agreement why did i write that
it's not written up in the paris
agreement that you can't do um solar
radiation management
it was just an unforced error as far as
i'm concerned and i would revise it i
might even revise it going forward but
it almost doesn't matter
maybe it implies that there was a
treaty passed don't do this on your own
um international governance people are
working on that right now very hard
a method of deciding if whether or not
to do solar radiation management as
being global and maybe a messing with
the monsoon
if india decided to do it because they
were suffering the rest of the world
would just have to say
you know um
okay you did it there was there would be
no sanctions and there would be no moral
right to sanction them
it is important to add to social
radiation management although we base it
on pinatubo
and sulfur dioxide which would work
sulfur dioxide uh burns up the ozone
layer and is bad in quantities so you
would need it to be limestone dust
and um limestone dust is already up
there it has similar effect it's inert
and drops back down to the ground in the
way that normal dust does
and there wouldn't be a termination
shock if you did it once it would be
like pinatubo for five years it had
lower temperatures the dust would come
to the ground you could figure out
whether you wanted to do it again as an
emergency major if people were being
cooked alive so even geoengineering well
i think this is my role as a science
fiction writer every
i mean the man from mars every thing
should be on the table
um including things like this that
ordinary american liberal leftists would
say oh my god you can't do that but why
in 1990 there might have been a moral
hazard
now it's all hands on deck and it might
be break glass for emergency usage drop
temperatures for five years
see what happens i mean i really think
that's a possibility
i'm with you um on that note stuart
brandt asked what do you think of neil
stevenson's discrimination shock
i haven't read it neil and i we we are
it's this is maybe um the doppelganger
the narcissism of small differences we
don't read each other they would be a
freak out
total freak out
i i very much like neil personally
and i've seen him
um
entrance a table of nasa scientists with
his um
his um
spinning table takeoff device
and he's
what pages of him i've have read from
diamond age or cryptonomicon a few pages
here there just to see what he's like
he's very funny i'm envious
it's hard to write comedy and he seems
to be good at it but i don't know um
from what i've heard about termination
shock it's like come on neil
we got a serious problem here
it's not time to have
eagles
um
killing robots in the sky over texas or
whatever the hell
but i haven't read it so presumably it's
a
stewart stewart does say we should box
it uh with ministries yeah
yeah get the yin and the yang or the
kneel on the stand i mean you have to
notice this
the his baroque cycle is the same time
as my galileo's dream his seven eaves is
the same time as my aurora
and now termination shock and ministry
for the future
he has good judgment in terms of stories
all right
um it's a time check what is our end
time zanner
wrapping it up so let's ask a couple
questions about sci-fi itself about and
writing so kevin asks uh what would you
write differently now any of your books
you'd go back and change
oh well a couple i would i would
disappear entirely
the old zap the zap-o-matic and but
everything since
um
that that goes back into my youth i must
say and i and my youthful self would be
extremely irritated with me for being so
condescending
um
probably those are masterpieces that i
can't recognize anymore
um but everything since the gold coast i
would stand i would stand by and that's
1988 so what the hell i
there are
i was very intensely frustrated by
pacific edge where i didn't manage to
tell the history of how they got to
their utopia and that brought the mars
trilogy into existence i was very
frustrated with what i now call green
earth that trilogy in washington dc
science in the capital what a gnarly
beast of a place is the washington dc
bureaucracy never said a novel there
you could see that in the novel i busted
out into rock creek park and went feral
on purpose to try to make the novel work
better but that was a frustration to me
in a couple in a couple cases um initial
conditions you know fundamental choices
you make at the beginning of the novel
you can be a really good craftsman and
technicians of novels and you're still
working on a crap idea to begin with
and so that's where i feel the stress
and strain but some people just love
pacific edge some it's corey doctorow's
favorite novel of mine um and so you
gotta
not be too ungenerous to your past self
and
i just leave it all the same
awesome
um
so actually we were talking before that
started we think we saw each other in
london in like 2014 and you said you
shaman has come out and you said i've
got one or two more books in me you've
had four novels come out since then i
think you've got 21 or 22 novels out
some number of short story questions and
so on uh are we going to look forward to
more books from you uh please yeah yeah
yeah
i would want to say this my editor tim
holman at urban books
he gave me my 60s
and artists don't usually have a
well-platformed and encouraged 60s it's
a time of disarray and retreat
one artist in 10 has a
a well supported 60s because artistic
lifetimes are shorter than biological
lifetimes and people want the new
so um i was feeling that and it was
partly because of that damn dc novel but
tim holman said no no no um
try
uh i'll just buy three novels from you
we'll figure out what they are later and
and and boom uh i did that twice with
him and i just love this guy because he
gave me my sixties had six novels in ten
years and i like all six of those novels
very much
because of that sense of
security whilst i knew what i was doing
and my kids were growing up i could just
work every day and i worked every day
for 10 years now i'm not going to do
that
i'm done
but i'm not done done i'm just gonna
give ministry a chance to cook for a
while and one thing i want to try and
you'll see whether it comes true or not
but i think i can do it i want to write
short novels
i want them to be 125 pages long and and
do the deed because there are some short
novels that knock your socks off but how
did they do that i'm i'm a little
mystified
but i want to learn that i'm not so yes
i'm going to write more they're going to
be shorter
and
i need to have some ideas but i've got
some ideas so yeah
awesome last question i promise uh
what gives you the most hope for the
future
oh god well
um
well
the memory of my mom gives me the most
hope because she was a hopeful person
and she did it by
willpower it was partly biochemical but
it was partly a moral attitude you hope
first of all because you're alive and
hunger is a kind of a hope and bacteria
have hope hope is
um subtle but
omnipresent
so then political hope it's it's
gramsci pessimism of the intellect
optimism of the will
you will it as a way to go forward and
you know you do it for the future
generations
you do it for the people in the world
who are immiserated right now and like
if we don't have hope how come they have
hope and so it's almost a moral
imperative so that's what gives me hope
is that hope itself is intensely uh
tenacious
and
it will
we're going to have to suffer some
amazing
defeats reversals confusions violences
it's going to be an unholy mess the
2020s i guess i'll end with this
is it weird
the the are the 2020s really a critical
decade in all human history and earth on
life on earth history
that strikes me as suspicious
the the principle of mediocrity would
say we're not that special there's
something going on here we're just
worried or or we're self-important but
then when you look at everything you're
thinking well you don't want a six uh
sixth grade mass extinction in earth's
history
that would be big that would be hard on
us um maybe this is an important decade
so you have to be hopeful in order to
squeak through this important decade the
will to hope yeah it's a willed
experience
fantastic i like that better than the
wilderpower so everybody stan robinson
[Applause]
all right
thank you
thank you
you